I Susan Margaret Bruce returning
officers at the entrance sounds of our
constituency declare it that the total
number of votes given to each candidate
was as follows breaks miles Edward Frank
Scottish conservative and unionist eight
thousand and six hundred and twenty six
folks
Corydon Anthony Scottish Socialist Party
197
Leo William Scottish National Party
16650 six
Marshall for UK Independence Party 601
mayor Phil Stewart Scottish Green Party
2019
in Scottish Labour Party 19
1823 notice that Ian Murray is June
elected as the Member of Parliament the
end result for our constituency
total number of votes cast across the
Eddie Marsan Poirot constituency at the
UK parliamentary election on 7th of May
2015 was 49 thousand three hundred and
forty the total number of ballot papers
rejected or fifty four which is 0.11%
the turn Eriksson for the constituency
was seventy four point ninety eight
percent thank you
thank you very much you need and if
anyone seen my acceptance speech in 2010
I can assure you have had to prepare
this one can I fight that a tawny
officer and wish you well in your own
planning that later on this year soothes
and I wish thank everyone all the
coating agents everyone is counted this
evening all the pulling agents whose
staffed on polling stations so well
today
and indeed the police for all they do in
our communities so what did they also
speak pay special tribute to people have
supported my office over the last five
years my men toasty office team of
Leslie Caitlyn Stewart and Meredith are
the backbone of all we do locally and
they deserve all my agent Paul McCauley
who has been with us since the very
beginning
he is spearheading the most of
everything positive and inclusive
general election campaign and his
wonderful wife Jim of the big lines to
get him back tomorrow
kind of like super campaign to each and
every one of you of remarkable people
who won this election I couldn't be more
proud of our campaign and every single
one of you and a special thank you to my
lovely partner Hana the sacrifices you
need to do this job are worn by those
closest to you thank you many many who's
dedicated and hardworking who fled piece
of lost their seats tonight Sheila Gill
and Martha Sullivan chef's represented
their constituents every minute of every
day that local record of Sara's no
message to those who have won tonight
but let's also remember the staff to who
lose their jobs this evening the
companies in Colin film Neil and - it's
been a good-natured campaign and all
your activists have conduct themselves
impeccably the people of Minnesota
through their faith opinion that was
represent all of you regardless of how
you voted today for the next five years
tonight congratulations go to the
Scottish National Party and all their
successful candidates one of them they
have achieved but having built the hopes
and aspirations of sports
you're never charged with meeting those
heavy responsibilities you can up there
hang from the bar believe others but not
meeting those promises
so that means a strong liberal party
for the citations of people who read a
text message to tell that we had worked
that day for the pensioners to have to
decide between he take anything for the
most vulnerable people people like my
mother there was less with two young
boys when my father died I was left to
fend for herself back in the 1980s
that's why Scott the means a strong
liberal party we are entering a new era
of constitutional politics
constitutional politics is never built
the school never staff the hospital and
never lifted a chair poverty we will
listen but one thing's for sure always
fight for Scotland always fight for
equality and always fight for social
justice and that one begins
I'm sorry sleeper will not let you die
thank you